quand j'étais enfant je me voyais comme
à la télé en compagnie de poly le poney
à crinière blonde chevauchée dans les
grands espaces comme les indiens cheveux
et crinière au vent
quelque chose d'évident avec le cheval
qu'on pouvait s'en faire un ami vers
l'âge de 11 ans m'a confié à paul et je
vais donc immédiatement baptisé poli
mais la relation est poli était
compliquée pas du tout évidente comme
dans le film
alors les adultes eux m'ont dit c'est
normal muriel il faut que tu apprennes
il est vrai que le poney tout comme moi
n'étions pas à des bourrées ou éduquer
et je me suis dit c'est comme à l'école
ça s'apprend enfin le grand jour arrive
l'apprentissage dans une école
d'équitation et là il y à bien une
technique mais elle fait abstraction du
cheval l'intention n'est pas d'être en
relation avec lui comme je l'avais rêvé
mais de le faire obéir sans doute je ne
suis pas douée où il me faut du temps
pour apprendre
alors je persévère je côtoie d'autres
écoles et vers l'âge de 19 ans j'achète
mon premier cheval que je re baptise
ouragans je continue de pratiquer entre
être encadrés dans une école et mon
expérience plus personnelle avec
ouragans c'est un impulsif un trotteur
réformes et des courses alors chevauché
comme les indiens c'est un peu risqué et
pourtant cette relation harmonieuse avec
ce cheval doit bien exister quand même
ce n'est pas que du cinéma
l'année 2000 l'année de tous les
possibles ou le meilleur comme le pire
est annoncée pour l'humanité pour moi
c'est un licenciement économique
bonne ou mauvaise nouvelle et bien
maintenant j'ai pleinement le temps pour
le consacrer aux chevaux mais ce n'est
plus le boulou on ne peut pas tout avoir
non sans inquiétude pour mon avenir je
me laisse guider par les événements de
la vie et j'entends parler d'un cow-boy
à de paris
à cette même époque je suis interpellé
par le film l'homme qui murmurait à
l'oreille des chevaux
pat parelli tout comme le personnage de
redford dans le film propose une
relation différente avec le cheval son
approche est basée sur trois mots love
language and leadership amour langage et
leadership
il a créé une méthode pour mettre à la
portée de tous le concept horsemanship
ou homme de cheval c'est à dire
l'équilibré parfait entre le relationnel
et la technique 1 une précision
importante la méthode et pour l'humain
pas pour le cheval le cheval en
bénéficiera si l'humain développe
feeling est timing justesse et à-propos
pas de paris dit il dit qu'il n'a rien
inventé c'est tellement vieux cette
capacité de liens que nous l'avons
oublié alors de rencontre en rencontre
quelques mois plus tard tu me retrouve
au montana dans ce fameux pays de
l'homme qui murmurait à l'oreille des
chevaux et le chauffeur de taxi me dit
en arrivant au ranch mais qu'elle vous
faire ici pendant une année
il n'y a rien je réponds mais il y a
tout avantage de 45 mille hectares au
pied des rocheuses 2500 h une centaine
de chevaux des cowboys qui vivent auprès
du bétail et pour qui le travail avec
les chevaux est encore un mode de vie
c'est dans ce décor rêvé que tout prend
forme pour moi l'apprentissage commence
par le travail à pied aux côtés du
cheval par un lien de communication
matérialiser ici par la corde
je transmets mon intention a plus ou
moins de distance sans ce travail
d'ordre relationnel plus que technique
les chevaux sont des êtres puissant et
réactif et bien que domestiques et il
garde une part sauvage leur instinct de
survie et la fuite
ils sont donc naturellement plus ou
moins claustrophobe
par conséquent les amener embarqués dans
un camion dans un véhicule pour les
transporter peut-être quelque chose de
difficile pour eux parce que c'est un
passage étroit instable et sombre la
qualité de la relation est donc
essentiel le cheval n'a pas besoin de
qualités physiques particulières pour
embarquer cela est d'ordre mental et
émotionnel
il me suffit donc de l'inviter à
embarquer et débarquer en toute sécurité
la démarche qui m'anime alors et
d'obtenir la collaboration
l'adhésion à travers la confiance une
toute autre option que d'essayer de le
forcer
et un peu de bon sens me dis que de
toute façon je ne fais pas le poids
que valent mes modestes 50 kg contre ces
500 kg il s'agit donc d'être à la
hauteur de la conversation
une conversation en mouvement un jeu de
questions réponses un essai dans la
compréhension de ce jus relationnel
corporels que je prends conscience que
je ne pourrai plus agir autrement la clé
la communication à travers une intention
claire nette et précise qu'ils me
donnent une attitude stable et sereine
qui donne confiance
l'animal est loyal il nous prévient
toujours de son mécontentement de son
incompréhension de sa désapprobation
à nous d'être à l'écouté des signes
avant-coureurs parfois subtiles c'est
ainsi qu'un jour dans un travail à pied
je me trouvais donc aux côtés du cheval
et mon intention n'était pas vraiment
relationnel mais plutôt obéissance et
sans vraiment de conscience alors je
n'ai rien eu le temps de voir venir
j'ai reçu
un coup de pied en pleine poitrine
suffisamment fort pour que je comprenne
sont toutefois être blessé ce coup de
pied aurait pu me tuer un autre jour
dans un box
j'étais pressé je vous les déplacez le
cheval la nouveau ont l'intention
n'était pas relationnel mais à nouveau
obéissance et sans vraiment de
conscience résultats morsure à la fesse
et rien qu en l'évoquant je ressens
encore la puissance de la mâchoire sur
le muscle ça calme
ces deux épisodes me ramène à la réalité
comment je demande avec quelle rester de
l'autre et je réalise que ce n'est pas
tellement ce que je demande à l'autre
qui l'indisposent mais ma manière de le
demander et le cheval le remet à ma
place dans une juste façon de
communiquer je vais là toujours une
intention claire une réponse honnête à
nous proposer
et nous avec les humains comme avec des
cheveux nous avons tout à gagner à
travailler la clarté de l'intention si
nous tentions nous aussi de communiquer
sans arrière pensée sans ambiguïté je
suis resté une année au montana et le
jour du départ je pleurais ses grands
espaces allez me manquer montana wyoming
les rocheuses évoqué pour moi cheval et
liberté sans doute un rappel du rêve
indien
l'apprentissage selon pas de paris lui
aura duré environ deux ans et demi en
partie aux états unis en partie en
france il met alors évident que la suite
de ma vie sera transmettre et on s'est
lié au programme se bâtit autour d'un
bel idéal transmettre comment obtenir
une meilleure relation grâce à une
communication plus consciente
et cela pour chacun d'entre nous pour
tout le monde pas seulement les
cavaliers mes élèves en apprennent
beaucoup sur eux mêmes à travers les
chevaux et leurs réactions
ils deviennent conscients des signes
qu'ils aimaient de façon très concrète
si j'attends le cheval à temps si je
doute
il doute et si je me mets en mouvement
il se met en mouvement il est miroir de
mon attitude c'est expérience forte et
riche en émotions sont inscrits dans
notre corps et elles nous permettent de
prendre conscience de quelle est ma part
de responsabilité dans la relation
chacun a sa part et si chacun poser un
regard sur sa part de responsabilité les
qualités que me demande le cheval pour
être en relation avec lui sur les mêmes
que celles qui le sont nécessaires pour
être en relation avec les humains il
nous est un rappel
comment ont fédéré obtenir l'adhésion
si je ne me sens pas légitime je ne sais
pas prendre ma place au sein d'une
équipe équipe tout comme le cheval sera
miroir de mon attitude
comment donner confiance c'est moi même
je doute non manipulateur ni manipulable
hors statut et or affecte le chevalet
dans une pureté relationnel qui nous
amène à être dans l'exigence de la
pureté de l'intention c'est pourquoi ils
arrêtent gets de l'entreprise libérer le
surnomme le gardien de l'intention alors
voilà le secret pour voir l'invisible
il suffit d'allumer la lumière lunaire
et la conscience la conscience de nos
intentions et le cheval est un
merveilleux guide
merci